what does it feel like to be here in
Levin for the first stop on the grand
chest tour very nice I mean I like Levin
a lot it's a very nice town and so I'm
happy to be back here we play in a
really inspiring venue I'm looking
forward to the tour starting this year
it's much more open than most because
the guy who dominated the last two
events isn't here
it's great to be back and generally this
year's format when all the results count
make this event extremely important I
just finished the tournament and now I
think it was kind of a good warm-up I'm
actually first time in Leuven this
Grantchester is a great tool so it's
very nice to be part of it I was here
two years ago for the inaugural
Grantchester and it's great to be back
I'm looking forward to playing as all
these top guys again and certainly
coming off my result nor I feel pretty
good it's pleasure to be back here and
up 48 it would be a good start for me
for for this season of the country
strong I will try to play first time in
Grand Tour it is very nice event very
interesting rapid village and also one
classical tournament but I hope was just
overs will enjoy from our games
I think Grantchester been taking place
before for years already I've
participated in the first two tours
entirely and the last two times I played
in the 11th tournament
you know looking forward to big
challenges and this certainly is well
but yeah it's an exciting tournament
because it's the first stage of the
grand gesture I've always liked playing
here in Leoben Belgium it's a wonderful
city I'm excited because I haven't
played a rapid
event in a while but I haven't really
played of
all inclusive a quick time at all that
in life